[Music]
today we want to talk about self-service
analytics and our new product our studio
konnekt that we released we did a South
watch earlier this year you can download
evaluation on at any time hopefully some
people that are in attendance they have
seen it we want to give you an
explanation of you know why our studio
konnekt and the value that we think that
it adds to organizations and you know
how to get the most out of it so I'm
gonna walk through a few you know
background slides here talk about our
product stack a little bit you're
familiar with our CEO IDE we're also
going to talk about the packages a
little bit because they tie all these
things together specifically shiny and
our markdown and also this thing called
a tidy verse and then our new product
our studio konnekt so first I just want
to cover the tidy verse if you haven't
seen the tidy verse it's a collection of
our packages that share common
philosophies and are designed to work
together these are a lot of packages
that had these team has put together or
worked on and you can read about them in
our for data science which is a book
that I had Lee and Garrett wrote it's
free its online or you can buy it
through a publisher if you'd like the
tidy verse can be looked installed and
loaded very easily just by including
tidy verse and what happens is it will
load up all of these package that you
see on your screen the idea of the tidy
verses that you'll be using these to
create you know analyses and
visualizations and do your work in a
very fluid way and that's what I
actually want to talk about next is this
process of doing analytics so most
people have a you know some set of data
that they start with and then they you
know import that data they clean it up
then they try to understand their data
ready to go through this cycle of
transforming visualizing modeling their
data and when when you're done with that
you want to communicate what you learned
to other people you want to share the
insights and the understandings of
people and then
involves involves publishing either some
sort of documentation or visualization
or application so this this workflow
here this process workflow of
programming and data science is the way
we kind of conceptualize doing data
science with our and this is what the R
for data science book is a lot of what
it's about is kind of managing this
workflow and providing the tools to do
this effectively so today we're going to
be talking about this last part of the
workflow which is communicate so that's
what we want to talk to you today about
is communicating and communicating
involves two parties the first party is
the content creator and who is the
content creator well that's the data
scientists the domain experts or the app
developers and their job is to
understand and measure prediction
optimize you know systems and analyses
on top of their data and the output of
that understanding is typically
artifacts so you know documents again
applications or plots or whatnot then
you have the content consumers these are
the people that are the managers the
peers maybe other students these people
may or may not even understand are or
even have a great background in
analytics but their job is to take what
you learn what you do and make decisions
and take actions and see results so
these content consumers are extremely
important in your taking advantage of
the artifacts that are being created in
a typical process workflow and this is
what I'm very familiar with so I'm an
analyst by training abuse are for a long
time I go into our and I you know create
my now analysis when I'm done I make a
report and I send it on to the consumers
by an email or SharePoint or put it on
the file share somewhere that's a very
traditional way of sharing your analysis
and what happens when you do that
invariably somebody asks a question and
they say you know there's an error here
or I want to see more or I want to go
deeper so the content creator goes back
to work opens up their code and creates
a new artifact in our
then pushed back to the content
consumers and the cycle repeats and this
can be a very time-consuming cycle right
so the question is you know can we do
better can we be more efficient in the
way that this cycle is managed and yes
there there are ways to make this better
and one of those ways is to create
something that might be you know
self-service so wouldn't it be great if
instead of the content consumer asking
the content creator a question if they
could just go back to the artifact and
ask that question and get the answer
from the artifact itself it would also
be great if you could schedule and
distribute these reports and without
having to do it in a manual process so
if you have a dashboard that you need
updated every week maybe the system can
handle that if you want to distribute it
one version of the report to one group
and another version of report to another
group maybe the system can handle that
and would it be great if all this
content just read naturally natively in
our write because that's the language
that we know so we want to be able to
make sure that the system can run all
this natively in our can serve up shiny
apps in our markdown documents and
finally would it be great if we can just
pass much more of the control that we
typically maintain in our daily work to
the content consumers and allow those
content consumers to have some of that
control to get the answers that they
need to run our even if they don't know
how to use our to schedule the reports
and get and take action on the analyses
on their own so that's what our studio
konnekt is designed to handle that's
what we're going to be talking about
next so my colleague Sean is going to
talk a little bit about these different
types of artifacts the first one is
going to be this static document right
where you just have a very basic our
markdown document and then he's going to
talk about parameterised documents and
how powerful that those are and then
he's finally going to talk about
application development and hosting
applications in a way that consumers can
take you know control of those
applications so I don't want to take any
more time away from the demos let's
dive in and see what we have and I will
pass the baton over to Sean then so
thanks for it for that introduction
Nathan what we're going to be talking
about today just as Nathan said is how
to get that control over to the end
users and make your lives as data
scientists be easier and we're gonna be
doing that with content and content has
to have a data source so our data source
today is going to be this Star Wars API
or sloppy for short this is a great data
set it's a lot of fun if you're a star
Wars fan like me it's a fitting the
latest trail trailer just came out and
this dataset contains all kinds of crazy
information on everything from
characters and films to physical
characteristics of home planets and so
we'll be digging into that a little bit
today so I'm going to start inside of
our studio just to help us get our
bearings a little bit I'm using a flavor
of our studio called our studio server
Pro CNC I've accessed our studio through
a web browser which might be new to some
of you I thought otherwise that the IDs
it exactly the same and everything that
I'm going to show you today you'll be
able to do inside of our studio open
source server or studio server Pro or
just on our show your desktop which is
most likely what you guys are using
alright so as Nathan mentioned one of
the most common forms of communication
and communicating the results of
analysis is just with a static piece of
content and one of the again most
popular pieces of static content are
just plots and visualizations so that's
what we're going to start off with today
so Nathan mentioned the tidy verse I'm
going to use the the tidy verse
throughout the demos and all these demos
are going to be online afterwards so you
can play around if the code yourself
when you run this command library tidy
verse it pulls in a whole bunch of those
packages